- I have taught AP Physics
classes for the last seven years.
AP Physics One, AP Physics B,
back in the day, and AP Physics C now.
I try to make my lessons personable,
relate to the student,
offer them real life
examples where things happen,
but also focus on, instead of,
a bunch of little memorization facts,
like, what's the big idea that helps
you figure out all these
different situations for,
allows you to be a more
robust problem solver.
So, we're focusing on the big core ideas
of our subject, being physics,
and I think you'll find that across
all the different AP content subjects.
We are finely tuned
to what the AP exam
is gonna be like, directly.
And we are building in
videos for instructions,
specific to that, and also we have
practice exercises that
I'm really excited about,
that, you can assign it to students,
and there's hints, and there's feedback,
why a certain problem is wrong,
and why a certain problem is right.
And then it shows you the solution path
of how you would get to the solution.
So, when you assign a student a problem,
they don't have to wait a whole
24 hours, until they get back to class.
They can get it wrong, fail early,
try another one, fail often,
and do a couple times on that.
And I actually think my students
might actually do more,
homework, 'cause they're getting
instant feedback on the process,
rather than just trying a couple,
and getting stuck, and like,
"Ah, I'm frustrated, I'm outta here."
They can really
get in the seat,
and stay in it, because they're getting
instant feedback and help as they're
working through problems.
I think that's gonna be really powerful.